what uh hold on
who are you your worst nightmare the
cartel the Nintendo company Nintendo is
this yours I'm taking this this is mine
now I grew up playing your games I love
Mario hey hey hey that's copywriter
material put that away put it away uh
what were you just doing right now I
made this video where I modded Mario to
look like Walter White and it's stupid I
mean this with no exaggeration you
deserve to die just relax I don't want
to relax I want to destroy you because
of the Mario thing copyright Mario
strike because I said Mario that name is
copyrighted material you idiot how do
you benefit from this our analysts
calculated that you lost us point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent of profits
sorry sorry is not enough on Nintendo
you make great games but this kind of
behavior gives you a terrible reputation
this attitude doesn't work in the
internet era what is the internet okay
well like that explains some of it I
guess maybe you're right you know maybe
as a company we should change our
perspectives a little bit grow with the
top